welcome to our new and Wolfram language
12 webinar series it's great to have so
many of you on line with us today this
is the first session in a four-part
series that will cover significant areas
of new and expanded functionality in
Mathematica and the Wolfram language my
name is Jamie Petersen and I'm the
technical programs manager for Wolfram
you a free and open learning hub that
features interactive courses video
classes and webinars like this one thank
you for joining us
last month Stephen Wolfram announced the
release of version 12 with a blog post
highlighting many of the topics we'll
explore live and in-person with the
function developers and code experts in
this webinar series in upcoming sessions
will cover mathematics scientific
visualization extended capabilities of a
Wolfram knowledge base and integration
with external and real world systems
we'll send you reminders for each
upcoming session and hope that you'll
join us for all four webinars in the
series today's topics will bring you up
to speed with the latest in machine
learning and neural networks in the
Wolfram language joining us are at TN
Barnard our lead architect for machine
learning who will talk to us about the
new machine learning super functions and
Mateos Alvarez I am a machine learning
developer who will speak on the latest
developments to the neural net framework
also joining us is shadi ash Nye manager
of image and signal processing and Carlo
Giacometti a developer of the audio
processing capabilities in the language
we'll be presenting on machine learning
for images and audio our final
presentation will be about the recent
advances in deep learning for natural
language processing so let's get started
with a poll question that'll help us
understand who is here in the audience
with us this poll question asks you
about your experience with Mathematica
and the Wolfram language and we have a
lot of people online with us it may take
just a few seconds for this poll to show
up on your screen but thank you for
submitting your answers we'll post the
results so you have a chance to also see
who has joined us online and where
everybody's at
so far I'm seeing the results come in
it's it's a very nice mix about a third
for each response new to the Wolfram
language used it in the past but not
recently and then current and active
users so it is great to see so many
already familiar with the Wolfram
language this will serve as a great
update for you on what the latest
technology is in the new version version
12 I think we're just about ready to
close that poll and share those results
with you yep so really about half our
current users in our audience today
thank you for being here and we're we're
glad to see people who are new to
Mathematica and the Wolfram language and
and you know eager to check out its
capabilities so thank you everybody for
being with us the second point I want to
ask asked specifically about the version
of the Wolfram language that you are
using the neural net framework was
introduced in version 11 so it'd be good
for us to get a feeling for who's here
and if you've seen the neural net
framework before how much of this
functionality is brand new to you so
once again when this poll question shows
up on your screen go ahead and give us
your results and we appreciate your
responses to this question as well so
again we're getting a good mix but looks
like already I'm seeing half of you have
already have version 12 and that's
fantastic
and if you haven't upgraded yet or
you're still kind of considering your
options this webinar should give you
some very good information and
motivation to do so okay we've got those
results coming in let's go ahead and
share those yep perfect thank you that's
really good information for us finally
there's one last poll before we get into
our presentations today and this one
asks about your experience with machine
learning in general not necessarily with
the Wolfram language but how how much
experience you have using neural Nets
pre trained or if you've trained your
own neural networks and while we're
collecting the final responses to this
poll it gives me a chance to point out
control panel on the right side of your
screen which is an important part of
your experience today you should see a
couple of icons you can click to open up
question and chat panes the icon that
looks like a speech bubble with a
question mark inside it you can use that
to open the question question pane and
type any questions you have for us today
you can submit them anytime during the
presentations our developers and
engineers are on line with us to type
responses to your questions throughout
the webinar the talk bubble with the
three dots or ellipses inside it will
open the chat pane where you can send
and read messages finally we've had good
success with Firefox and Chrome browsers
so if you experience any problems with
the screen or audio streaming you might
want to try to exit and re-enter using
one of those browsers ok thank you
so those poll results are ready and most
are new to machine learning with another
35% having some experience thank you
very much for that response let me also
tell you if you need assistance in
getting your version 12 upgrade or with
installations support we have customer
service reps here with us to online so
go ahead and you could type your
location details your license number
your activation key anything that helps
them with your account into the question
pane and we have people online right now
who can help you with any of those
upgrade or installation questions that
you have so with that out of the way I
think we're ready to get started with
our presentations I'm ready to pass the
microphone to Etienne and he'll be
presenting on the machine learning super
functions all right Thank You Jamie so
indeed I'm going to present the new high
level machine learning functions that we
added in 12 which are automatic machine
learning functions and we often call
them super machine learning super
functions so I'm going to focus really
on the most recent one that I've been
added just for this version I won't talk
about the the function that I did I
didn't even on three eleven point two
eleven point one but you can see the
on our product page that is kind of
giving you overview is like nice
examples of all these these editions and
so in particular I'm going to talk about
the new unsupervised learning functions
that I call learn distribution something
to synthesize missing values and
something to find anomalies so just to
make everything clear these are
automatic machine learning functions I'm
not going to talk about me or networks
here you'll have many other session
talking about neural networks after this
is a little bit different the idea is to
be able to do to solve math learning
problems without requiring a lot of
expertise or in a very easy way even if
you are an expert you can still use them
in order to a baseline and to things
where to prototype things very fast ok
so what is learn distribution oh and I
should mention because I see that many
people will new with Mathematica on you
in machine learning so these are I guess
a little bit more advanced function but
with this classic functions just
classify and predict that are usually
more classic and then you can you can
find that on documentation and webinars
and and so on alright so learn
distribution the goal is to as its name
says to learn the probability
distribution of data okay so be able to
assign for new data point probability
density value be able to sample new data
from this distribution and and other
things and this ability to learn
distribution unlocks many applications
such as animal detection and missing
imputation synthesizing new examples
correcting errors as well
that's why are often referred to this as
the holy grail of unsupervised learning
and as something we've been waiting a
long time to have in the language so I'm
pretty excited that we have it now so
let me show you very simple examples
let's say the data set is just five
examples which is like a a BB
Catterick available I can run and
distribution on it it returns a learn
distribution object that you can ask
information about it by the way this is
something new in 12 you have this
information function that you can apply
to many type of object like that and so
for example this says that the data type
was no me no okay that make sense that
the metal is contingency table which is
in that case equivalent to a categorical
distribution that's a loss okay and some
other of information so now with this
distribution the first thing I can do is
query well what is the probability of a
given the distribution and says it's
around zero 42 or what is the
probability of B given the distribution
and it says it's around 0.55 which in
that case is probability mass not
density because it's categorical viable
you can execute this is not 2/3 it's not
like 3/5 and 2/5 it's because there's
some regularization like the goal is
always to generalize to new data it's
not to fit the training data as good as
possible it's always to generalize to
external data and then you can all do
other things such as generate from the
distribution so if I generate many of
them you should say actually I could
could count them
let's see counts here you go so it
should generate a bit more B than a all
right let's hear a second example this
time on numeric data so I'm going to
load a data set which is by dimensional
that I said just for visualization
purpose but this can work for arbitrary
dimension so let's run land distribution
on it and actually I'm going to put a
time goal just for you to see a bit
what's happening underneath let's
suppose a bit fast so you have this this
panel that can of shows the progress of
the learning and and you can see all the
experiments that I've done because it's
an automatic machine learning function
so it tries many algorithms many
parameters to in the end
is the best distribution possible I mean
at least the best it can do so you see
this time it's kernel density estimation
that I've been selected so here I'm
going to plot the PDF so this is really
a density because it's numeric values so
you should show the original data and
okay so you can see the original data
and in the contour plot of the density
that line description found and again
you can sample you can do all sort of
things that I'm going to show a bit
later let me show you another example
that is done with colors just to show
that you can put a bit arbitrary data
type state you cannot put any data for
example is one bit restriction at the
moment you can put sequences so learning
distribution of text is not supported at
the moment but anything that doesn't
have a viable length you can put I mean
anything most things so here I learned
the distribution of these colors this
time it was a multi normal distribution
has been selected by the automatic
procedure and I can just generate random
value from the distribution or I can
carry the PDF from this distribution and
actually you can see it's interesting
like if I say okay given the
distribution what is the probability to
be this color red it's going to be an
extremely low probability green it's
also be extremely low and this scan of
this blue that is definitely not a blue
that we put in the training set as a low
probability but quite higher it's only 2
to the 10 minus 4 and this actually can
already give you hints that we can use
that for detecting anomalies in that if
you CRO in a PDF and if you see the PDF
is very low then it's probably that is
an anomalous example so you can have a
hint of one application all right but
let's start with synthesizing missing
values so here the goal is let's say you
have this picture of a nine but I mean I
know actually we don't know it could be
a seven and some pics are just unknown
so it's not their grades just that
unknown the idea would be to predict
what would be these unknown values and
the way we do that is that we train a
learned distribution on data set and
then we use the distribution by
conditioning the distribution on the
known values we can infer what is the
most likely unknown value or we can
sample the unknown value given the known
value so it's really purely about
conditioning a distribution that we
learn so that's that's a nice
application that we have with land
distribution so let me show on a data
set so here it's okay it's moons of
Jupiter you have the mass you are the
radius and some of them us is missing so
we'd like to fill that up but you don't
want to fill that up by having something
that is similar to all the other masses
because you see it's very different so
I'm at ten to twenty three is about ten
to the seventeen you want something that
makes sense given the radius and it's
just one out of coats and size missing
values and you go to Santa Santa sized
so this choose will learn distribution
on the on the back end actually it's
interesting you see that one is negative
so algorithm for didn't pick up that
there were all positives it did still
make more sense like in terms of
magnitude like they are all small masses
that have been added but it's because
it's sampling from the conditional
distribution you can also say oh
actually I want to find most likely
missing value by using mode finding so
this is a you can specify an evaluation
criteria you can also specify a method
for line distribution that will be used
for the imputation so in that case I'll
just say use them into normal and use
the mode and in that case there's no
there's no negative values okay let me
show now
example this one is bit more educational
so I'm going to data set that is
actually the same as we showed before
for the distribution so we're going to
learn the distribution this time and
directly use this distribution to do the
missing imputation or as we call it to
synthesize and listen values so okay I'm
going to show again distribution the
same plot as we showed before and so you
can use this time since as missing
values where the first arguments is a
distribution and the second argument is
a data you want to fill in okay so this
time it won't need to learn any
distribution you just use one that
already exists and I pick on peppers the
value 5 point 5 for X because it should
be by model so we should sometimes end
up by having the Y value imputed as
being something around you know between
1 & 2 and sometime between 4 & 5 so if I
do it many times you go night so four
nights one nine two two okay so I can
actually do 1,000 times and from this
1,000 imputation I'm going to show just
20 of them so here you see that in this
twenty some of them have been added here
and some of them a bit I did here I can
also do a histogram so it should be
bimodal histogram of the imputed value
and so yeah this is really to show that
it's it's a probabilistic imputation
which makes a lot of sense which is very
useful to know how you can rely on your
imputation because typically you're
going to impute missing values and then
do some processing after like training a
model or do whatever and if you do it
many times or imputation with the
sampling then you can figure out when
you look at the final result you can
compute uncertainty on the final result
and and I have an idea on how confident
you are in this result but you can still
have the like find the most likely value
and so apparently it's here that's the
mode of
of the of the conditioning so it's
really a line here okay let's continue
to the other application which is
animated diction so here I kind of
explained that on colors already the
idea is to learn distribution possibly
unknown I may lose data
sometime it's a bit hard to anonymous
data but and then to use the the PDF to
figure out a new data point is anomalous
or not but rather than PDF we introduced
a new concept called where probability
which i think is a very nice concept
that is not really I mean I didn't find
much in in in the academic literature
but it's related to other concepts so so
come to idea our probability is to ask
given this distribution and given this
data point how likely it is for this
distribution to generate a sample that
has a lower PDF than this data point
okay it takes usually a bit of time to
wrap your head around that but basically
to ask how extreme is this event how
rare is this event so for you to know
statistics this corresponds to this
double tail p-value in statistics in
that case because so you need you need
dimensional distribution but you can
generalize this concept to arbitrary
dimension this form for any distribution
you can always ask what is how extreme
it is event what is the probability to
find a rarer event and where a
probability and that's a nice framework
to think of anomalies all right so
that's that's that's what we use
underneath and that's what you can so
basically you with with the I mean I
will show you after with an option you
can specify what is where a probability
threshold you can say I want to
threshold to one of our million it means
that anytime you see an example that a
distribution says well there was only
one chance in a million that I can find
an event more extreme than this one then
you consider this event or this example
as anomalous okay let me show you an
example so here we actually take again a
signal that I set as before with two
numeric value and one of the function is
just fine anomaly so here we don't even
have to do anything it just asks for for
anomalies and here is a sort of cross
validation system where it takes part of
the data learn a distribution
test if the other part is anomalous and
do that several times to narrow down the
anomalous examples so I'm going to show
here okay that's what that's an example
that's the function fine anomalous but
again you can change this acceptance
threshold to say so actually if I were
doing acceptance resoled
10-6 which is pretty low we'd probably
find way less okay so only these two
phenomena is for some reason okay
so another function is value called
delete anomalies as well which does what
it's what it says there's also a
function called anomaly detection and
this time it will return a function a
bit like stolen distribution we showed
before that can be used on your data
just like a classifier
isn't anomaly or not so this one I put a
really high number here so definitely
should be an anomaly while this other
one is not an anomaly and you can ask
what I was saying before this word
probability and you can see that it's
pretty clear like often two anomalies
you have no problem detecting it even
with a bad distribution so that's why
even if land distribution is not perfect
for your data it might be enough to find
anomalies so this is a there's only 50
percent of chance or something wherever
here there's really really really tiny
chance to have something rarer than this
this thing and here is been an example
of what this outlier boundary would look
like so anything
over there should be considered
O'Malley's and everything here will be
considered nanomedicine okay
I'm going to okay I think it's still a
few minutes so so just another example
actually already trained that example
because it takes too long otherwise it's
all images and actually is to show you
that this okay I gave it I think 65
animate don't know maybe very less work
wait no no okay I gave to the word when
I'm sample
oh I changed data okay that's why okay I
get 50,000 example to animate detection
and if I do random sample it probably so
it's it's 50,000 images you're probably
not going to look like anything great
because it's a hard task to learn from
scratch distribution of images so so if
I run on variates of this distribution
which I hope oh I have to train it again
I messed up because I renamed oh wait
its output 71 okay I think we're gonna
cheat okay random bro
don't know it's not remember it okay
sorry sorry this is the anomaly detector
function it's not a distribution so
actually inside there is a distribution
so I could generate examples but I
cannot with this with this object fine
so we can ask the information as well so
you can see a little bit learning curve
what happened to learn this distribution
and this one I took one minute that's
why I didn't want to do it live and it's
just directly ad equalizer you go now I
can use it again so it consider that
this example animal is great now I'm
corrupting this example and most of them
consider that as anomalies and now what
I'm doing is that I giving values level
of corruption to an image and we're
going to see what's how the variability
behave so you can see that the real
property is pretty high for the original
image but when we start correcting the
probability is going pretty quickly down
and that's why as soon as like you set
your accident special as soon as below
it will consider the animals okay so I
hope this illustrate how anna-marie
detection works so just really quickly
on some other update that were in 12
with the new methods new neural network
method for classifying predict that now
uses self normalizing your networks
which is the really great architecture
for new networks to to manage to train
fully connected networks and therefore
being very versatile in one it be try
not it doesn't have to be image or sound
or things like that it can be trained on
regular structure data and give pretty
good results so so yeah big improvements
in in the neon network method and you
can specify all those Network depth and
the max training around we kind of
trimmed down the possibility of control
you have on this on this method to make
it more simple and more useful I think
like if you want to be
more expert then you have to go to the
New York firm work that you will hear
after so this would be the the results
of this framework and of this this
training and I could change the network
depth but I don't have much time so the
notebook will be given to all of you you
can play with that another tiny addition
is not as if I'm measurement returns a
certainty which i think is pretty useful
why lack uncertainties a lot so now when
you ask for the accuracy of a classifier
you can say compute instantly true and
return this around object that is a new
new in twelve so to have an idea so
basically if the test set was bigger
than the certainty the statistic on
strategy will would go down okay I think
that's that's it's for the machine
learning super functional thank you my
name is Matteo solver Itza I will
present the new features for the neural
network area so this is an outline of
the talk first I will talk about the
role as repository and the news the new
state-of-the-art models and the new
edition which is the polarized that
model syntax then I will move on
discussing the building blocks the new
building blocks in particular focusing
on the building blocks making the
transformer architecture possible VP
encoding then other layer last I will
present back and extensions and generic
speed ups and some useful training tools
you can use to mainly debug training the
monitor the training as it as it goes so
the in general the biggest the biggest
new features are in the area of MLP of
natural language processing so for the
neural net repository we we are we have
converted state-of-the-art NLP models so
right now we have these two so these
models so these are these are called
transformer models there is another one
which is which is GPT - which is also
coming soon so basically what these
models do they convert text into a
sequence of vectors encoding high-level
information about meaning of the text so
there they are they're essentially
feature extractors very high-level
feature extractors from text so for
example here we feed this can be in this
string to the model
this ring is converted to a sequence of
eight vectors and this vector and these
features are meaningful semantically so
as a demonstrations as very demo we can
define a set of sentences about food
music and obtain features for its for
each sentence by just picking the last
of these vectors for each one of those
and plot them into into feature space
and you can see food related sentences
and music written sentences form two
separate clusters so the meaning of the
sentence is encoded in the
representation produced by the network
so these are very powerful tools to
Train any and appear elated application
and and I will speak to later about the
Transformers the architecture of
Transformers and how you can implement
that in the language and for more
information you can also check the
example pages for these two models on
the neural net
three websites okay so second feature is
so called parameterized net models so
basically his many models actually are
actually part of my family so these are
old models we we have imported I believe
for 11.2 anyway it's it's very a common
to have models being part of our family
of models and so we've decided to
introduce an extended syntax for model
families which are not represented as
separate models but as a single model in
which you can choose the actual network
with parameters so for example for you
can query so this is a pair up a new
model for 12 which is parameterized and
you can query for each parameters using
the syntax parameters information so you
will get this nice data set this means
there are three parameters whose names
are language for camporee size and
dimension and you can you can see the
allowed values and defaults okay so the
default combination is a change through
an Oracle to that model wine for in
order to be a specific model you can
specify the parameter values using these
syntax and get another one
also yeah sometimes not all the
parameter combinations are present so in
that case you will get a nice failure
objects which tells you what is
available and by the way the
Transformers model for the transformer
models I showed you before are also
parametrized so this GPT has one
parameter which is which has two values
it's actually two networks so yeah we
will also look at these B P and B models
more in detail very soon actually in the
next slide because these is also very
powerful and B to to tokenize text in
any language yeah so to include these
this part more models are ready for
publication and we are going to use
Stepney say chief or more okay so on to
the blocks so I've told you about the
transformer so we'd be hard the
transformer is the new attention layer
which is a generalization of the old
sequence attention here we had it twelve
good so sequence attention layer is now
deprecated if you if you use it
a message will tell you and an attention
layer will be returned instead which is
equivalent so let's look at it in detail
so this is this this layer implements
generic key value query attention so for
those of you not familiar we were
Junction is let's let's pick a simple
case so in the simple case the input to
the key and value ports are sequences in
this case of length two of back doors so
some key the key vectors have three
dimensions you can also look at it here
and the value vectors at four dimensions
and we have a single queen vector of
dimension six so what in this simple
form what this layer does is it computes
this weighted average in which VI are
the value vectors of the of dimensions
the deep these scores are scalar so this
Z I are scalar scores computed for the
query vector and the the key factors so
these this layer basically computes all
the possible scalar Kirk scores between
all the keys and the queries and build
and construct some in a weighted average
on the value vectors
that this is useful in many like
sequence related applications you can
have oh and don't think I should mention
the weighted average F is computed using
a scoring net which which in this layer
is a completely generic completely
generic network so if you don't specify
it like in this case you have a default
one which is basically a dot product
there is a linear layer bringing the the
key to the correct dimensionality and
then it's just not product between the
query and the modified key but it can
also take generic scoring networks so in
its most generic form it can take a
generic scoring match so for example
adding let's graph which produces a real
and takes two vectors basically and I
can also work for arrays of arbitrary
rank for all three ports including
variable length sequences so it's a it's
very a it's very generic and powerful
tool so its main use cases are the usual
key value attention which you can
implement using this simple function so
in this case you have you have sequences
of queries and inputs out of the inputs
you usually build keys and values for
from layer using basic mapping a linear
layer over the sequence and feed
everything to the attention layer you
can also easily do multi hat attention
which is basically which is what is
using transformers which is basically
parallel attention blocks
khoka so each one of these is actually
valuable block and all of these are
competitive together so this is the
typical architecture you find in
transformers and this is how you so
another the other building block we need
is which is a much simpler one is what
is usually called layer norm in
literature and it's super multi in the
new normalization layer which is also
this one is also generalization of a
London layer which which is called in
for instance formalization layer which
is now deprecated and returns an
equivalent normalization later so
whatever ash layer does it's basically
can normalize input array is flexing Li
over generic levels and also apply learn
scaling and biases over generic levels
so and this is also a meeting block
needed to to build in the Transformers
okay onto the white parent coding agreed
so this is also this is a new feature
also very relevant for any P so might
vary encoding is an algorithm for text
segmentation that missing link purple a
smoothly between character level and
what levels implications so which means
you segment text directly in some words
which can be either a full word or a
single character or anything in between
so it hangs up the best of both worlds
and usually in common implementations
common words you go word level for
common words
so if you see hello you segment the
entire word but if you have rare words
or compound words or acronyms or
anything like that you usually use some
words so for example use you can segment
these
electroencephalogram into these three
pieces
you see this is very powerful because
then for example if you have another
word like electrolyte for example those
will likely be segmented you know you
will have the same initial token in both
and you already have knew you're making
in meaning already in the segmentation
because there are two things about
electricity okay and you get that for
free out on your taxing notation
algorithm so it's very powerful also for
this reason
so BP is a trained segmentation
algorithm so you don't come up you don't
have to basically come up with all the
words and sub words by yourself but you
train it on on raw text data and it's
not going to generated based on the
structure of data and the algorithm
naturally comes up with this nice
meaningful segmentation so yeah so
unfortunately for 12 training of me P is
not supported so you can obtain
pre-trained vp model models from either
net model or we support import of BP
model trade with sentence piece so you
can find a link in here this is a very
common this is the basically now it's
the reference implementation for me P
and models trained with this can be
imported in Mathematica and and then
will become a net encoder so all of
these is implemented into a netting
color of type B P sub or tokens so as
we've seen here so let's download
let's get another BPM be a model again
and let's extract using that extract its
inputs which is the encoder so this is
the P P somewhere tokens encoder
implementing the Performing sorry
performing the DB p segmentation
so if we feed this string we get out the
codes and each of these codes refer to a
token word or some word and we can
extract the tokens the entire set of
tokens from the encoder and see which
tokens does this code correspond to and
this is the way it's cemented these
sentence so you see it's picking some
word for the compound word and and then
everything else is just a word so I
should mention this is this model is
very useful it's very flexible because
it so it's parameterised model and it
contains bpe embeddings and and so and
so does also be peat organizers in
encoder for any language so this is a
very powerful NLP tool because it
immediately unlocks NLP applications for
for in any language you already have a
very colorful tokenizer we don't have to
do anything so we can define this simple
function which just tank an tokenize a
string you see the string in the
language and you get the tokenization
for that language using the appropriate
VP model so this will take a while
because in the screen ports like channel
models and extract the encoder but you
can see this is all the different
segmentations on the on the same
sentence in different languages and you
can see it's mostly using some words for
the compound word which is nice so as
for other layers we have new layers
ordering layer and extract layer this is
for ordering a sequence
a missus to extract part of a raise at
at runtime so this has two parts it
takes specific position input and array
input and it extracts the the position
you asked for and then we have
improvement to existing layers so we
shape layers become more flexible and we
are not the channel group parameters to
convolution the convolution layers which
has risen back to popularity mainly with
with mobile nets and also it has built
in a symmetric padding which you can
previously using padding layer now you
can do it you can do a symmetric padding
inside commercial ok so for the last
part this would be rather quick we have
some back and extensions and speed ups
most so most notably we have much faster
we currently years in CPU so creating
the current layer and here I am running
the layer over large batch of inputs
even with the timing and you can check
for yourself see let me point three
mistakes almost zero point five seconds
this is actually low estimate subsequent
we are slightly faster because it's
compiled the graph to CPU already but
anyway much faster recurrent layers and
sitting you but we finally have
multi-gpu training so when you see links
here this will redirect you to the new
interval pages in which these topics are
explored more in detail so now you can
you can train the network on some data
and you can do target evals to GPU come
all and it will handle paralyzation
automatically I can do it now because I
don't have a GPU on this laptop
more GPU improvements we support answer
course which is the new superfast media
architectures on new generation video
cards which has very less improvement
for convolutions and other operations
and you can you can you can opt into
that by
working precision was too mixed then we
also yeah as for working precision we
also support fully support 64-bit
calculations on the back end so usually
deep learning people girls go for 22
weeks because it's really enough but
sometimes for like maybe scientific
applications you want higher precision
and you can be meeting by selling
working position goes to us 64 up to
first so for the very last part we have
some new training tools and the training
functionalities so we have custom
properties so for example here I'm
training the network cover some data and
I'm not only asking for the final
network but for these custom results
which is you can see I specifying a plot
of the RMS of the gradients and will
match with plot options and so on so as
we train when training is over we will
get both a network and the plots and
this is very useful to understand what's
going on in training you can also
monitor what's going on online so just
not just after training but as training
progresses using this new option
training progress measurement so in this
case I will be monitoring the confusion
matrix f1 score and accuracy so in this
panel here I scroll down yeah there we
go
this is what I wanted to show you so you
can see the computer matrix involved
being live and the f1 scores well in
both the training and validation sets
and the accuracy and it's very flexible
you can ask for it if you want we we
also have flexible stopping criteria so
we did this new options training
stopping criterion so this means stop
training
if the f1 score doesn't improve for 100
iterations and you can see there is a
panel showing the f1 score as well so
yeah that was the plot for the f1 score
yeah so this is pretty much over the
only thing I want to mention is that we
have linked reverse with learning
environments so he's not really strictly
and with functionality but it's
something you can interact with you can
be learning on these things so you can
you can you can start doing the first
part learning in a more from language so
yeah these are simple environments and
you can perform actions on the
environment using this device execute
yeah you can check the regions on team
so yeah this is pretty much it
and so now next one should be shoddy
with image related functionality
thanks Mattel ok so we heard about great
functionalities coming from machine
learning and neural net frameworks let's
get a toy how can we use machine
learning for images as most of you may
know image processing has been a part of
the Wolfram language since version 7
main focus for us in the past few
releases was to make sure we leverage
from all the advanced modern machine
learning and neural net capabilities
that is coming into the language built
in the two main focuses for us has been
to make as Etienne said earlier super
functions that are built into this
system as well as making sure the
framework allows for any allows for
smooth workflows in order to develop
image processing image analysis image
generation whatever image related
functionalities a quick outline of what
I'm gonna talk about today is gonna be
built-in capabilities a quick look from
the image perspective on the Wolfram
neural net repository and then we're
gonna train a net from scratch use a net
in order to perform transfer learning
one family of functions that is
introduced in version 12 is the image
cases family so as far as object
recognition image cases is the main
function that can return sub sub images
of an image saying I found cups still
not stunning table or other things in
addition to that be about add more
direct functions to get just the
bounding boxes which can then get
highlighted on top of the image or just
the positions which is the mean of the
bounding box so easy additions to what
we have above but fairly useful if you
want to write a script that does just
one thing or another or does this image
include a cup and does this image
include a car and so forth a function
that wraps basically all of these
information into one big data set is
image contents and all of those are
built in expect improvements for the
number of categories and speed quality
all of that is on the track the
functions are marked experimental so and
that's the main reason is to make
improvements all along one of the
examples that we have created for new in
12 pages is using that same capability
to perform object recognition and
tracking in a video this is basically a
video of a dog or two people walking and
a dog passing by and then you can see
that frame by frame what we can do is to
basically check do we find the dog in
the video or in that frame and this is a
quick visual saying which frames had a
dog detected in
what was the position of it over time so
there are so many examples around video
that are basically working frame on
frame you in our new in 12 pages yes
there is gonna be work on actual
built-in video processing that is gonna
be more smooth no promise on mind that's
gonna happen the second category of
functions I would like to demo today is
fine faces and face analysis we have had
fine faces before but the results we're
shaky we have received a lot of feedback
from the users that their face is
missing a wrong face is detected and so
forth there is a huge improvement in
version 12 for finding more accurately
faces in an image so red here shows 11 3
results and green shows 12 results still
some faces may be missing again we're
looking into that another function along
those lines is facial features which is
basically looking into finding various
features from an image in this
particular case the default we are
basically getting age gender and emotion
but there are other properties like nose
points and eye points and outline points
and all of that which is being
calculated once it's done I can
highlight that on top of the image as
well let me enlarge just a bit ok
another function that they that I assume
a lot of you have seen already is
imagery style that is built into the
Wolfram language and again the the
built-in function is just one function
but there are various creative ways of
using functions to do different things
in this new and 12 example we are
showing style transfer to create art and
you can see that basically what is
happening image is being restyled to
itself
and then some features is showing up
after so many iterations you almost get
an abstract art out of that and so forth
a very neat example okay
the neural net repository as most of us
know images where the original drivers
for a lot of the new Aero neural net
development and as you see out of about
you know this is about 70 more percent
of the Nets that are in the neural net
repository there is a lot going on in
there different applications different
models different efficiencies and so
forth but what can we do with them so
number one we can obviously get a model
and then sometimes we have to create an
evaluation function around what comes
out of the network for instance in this
case the network gets a grayscale image
and then predicts the a and B Channel in
the LA B space so what we have to do
with the result is basically wrap it
into an image append or prepend the
luminance channel and create an LED
image which is happening in this case
there are a ton of more examples built
in that I have listed a few many more
other other than what I have listed many
many more planned to come now what is
the next big thing we can do with these
neural nets that that are available
through these repositories one very
useful case is to get a network that is
just get a hint from a structure of a
network and then train it on your data
set so in this particular case I'm
getting fashion amnesty which is a newer
version of Amnesty on various different
types of clothing and then I'm also
getting Linette uninitialized so if you
look at that none of the layers have
weights and then basically I trigger in
that train on that data set so all the
preparation is being done as soon as
that's over the training gets started
and then if
you wait enough this is gonna get done
and you get a train Lynette on fashion
M&S I've done this beforehand so I just
import the file and then start doing
measurements and analysis so for
instance in this case I'm running the
train neck on the test data on 90
percent accuracy I can show the
confusion matrix which shows some
obvious confusion between some of the
classes that are very close like boots
and shoes and things like that and here
I'm just showing a features face plot in
3d of some of those examples in the and
I believe test data set once that shows
we already see the nice reflection of
the good classification in that 3d
feature space plot as well so here we
started from a net structure
uninitialized train the whole thing what
if you don't have enough data to train
and network from scratch that's where
transferred Lane Learning Commons to
play comes into play so in this other
case in this other example I'm getting
an image classification network from the
repository
everything is pre trained and available
but I realized that the network is not
very good at separating camels from
dromedary and the reason is that there
is only one class defined when we were
when the network was being trained on
different classes of images so the one
thing that can be done is to do a little
bit of gymnastics or surgery on the on
the neck that was trained so in this
small piece of code we are dropping the
last two year layers we are adding a
layer to classify just between these two
classes that are of interest and and
basically that's about it so let's
define this new net and we can get
images from the web or any other
resource in this particular case I'm
just getting 50 images for each of the
two animals that I want to Train this on
if this takes longer when they don't
have to wait for it as I have trained
this again before on three hundred Sam
pulls from from each of the two classes
maybe just wait enough to get one of
those samples out then we concatenate
the two results with the two correct
classes that we wanted to train this on
and then that train begins so I'm not
going to wait for this other one we
basically call net train with that new
training set just the last layer the
classification layer needing to be
trained and let me again import the
network that I've trained before and on
the same two images that I had before we
see different classification so this was
a very quick rundown of what are the
things we currently have and whether
where are the places we think we should
continue developing and go forward there
are links in there thanks for being with
me next is going to be Carlo giving
basically the same applied talk for
audio analysis and audio processing
hello everyone my name is Carlo
Giacometti
I am a developer for the audio related
functionality in the voice of language
and today I will talk about machine
learning super function neural networks
applied on to audio signals audio
signals is a slightly newer topic for
neural networks than images but still it
does have a consistent amount of
applications and literature behind it so
I will first show you our new in new in
version 12 page for audio and machine
learning capabilities and so the the
main new things that we provide is
built-in functions for audio
identification speech recognition and we
have developed a very efficient and
tight integration both with the machine
learning and with the neural net
framework and this means that you can
have also access to a big number of
state-of-the-art preteen models to the
neural net repository either to just
evaluate or to use as stopping point for
transfer learning experiments and stuff
like that so first of all I wanted to
show you the main super functions that
we introduced in version 12 first of all
is the new speech recognition
capabilities okay so hopefully you will
also be able to is audio object playing
a job I guess energy speech recognizer
does a good job John understanding what
is spoken in that signal similarly to
speech recognizer we introduced some
functionality to detect the pitch of
monophonic signals I will show you the
output of this you can see that the
frequency of the signal is recognized
correctly and the last function that we
introduced that on its own might not be
super useful but is ends up being
crucial for other kinds of functionality
is already identified all you identify
takes a generic audio object and tries
to classify it in within a range of
predefined classes in this case it gets
things right it recognizes this sound as
an acoustic guitar and it works for many
different domains of sounds you can see
here I applied to all of our audio
example data and you can see we have
speech we have radio noise we have
animal sounds we have instrument sounds
and more environmental sounds etc etc so
these are the main machine machine
learning based super functions were
introduced another very important aspect
of introduced in version 12 is support
of audio objects in all of the high
level machine learning functions
and by high-level machine learning
functions I mean things like classify
and direct and feature space plot so all
of these functions leverage a variation
of the network is used in our
identifiers to extract semantically
meaningful features between audio
objects once you have these semantically
meaningful features you can compare them
and have a meaningful definition of a
distance for example between audio
signals so this type integration means
that the creation of audio classifiers
and predictors requires really minimal
input in this case I am collecting a
bunch of data hopefully will now
evaluate
let's see we got this to work so this is
a collection of 90 well the Train subset
of this that set is 90 signals of
acoustic guitars drums and trumpets the
length of these is variable it's less
than five seconds in general and I can
easily call classify on them I will not
do that now because of all the issues
that I'm having with screen sharing as
you can see the training time is very
sure I get a reasonable accuracy on the
training set and if I measure this on
the test set you can see and from this
specific choice of tested I even get a
100% accuracy and this as I said has no
user input it I just have a collection
of audio data and I just call
classifying them without doing any net
surgery or transfer learning or anything
everything is handled automatically by
classify and the same framework is
leveraged by feature space plot and Here
I am visualizing my collection of data
into a semantically meaningful space and
as you can see guitars are cluster drums
are nicely separated and trumpets are
also nicely separated and this doesn't
only work with instrument sounds I will
show you again on our full example data
or body signals this applies to many
difference domains and as I was saying
here you have animal sounds instrument
sounds speech music and more
environmental sounds so there are more
examples with high level machine
learning functions I will show them to
you in our product pages just because
the time is a bit tight in this example
I do automatically extract all your
features this is what I've shown you
before all of the data is plotted in a
semantically meaningful space and using
the same framework it is possible to
compute distances between all your audio
objects and it is possible to extract
also named features and plot named
features out of all the objects
similarly another interesting example is
the classification of an audio data set
this is a pretty standard data set of
environmental sounds the compiled is
comprised of 50 classes and it has 2000
environmental audio recordings and I
will try to classify this using just
top-level
high-level machine learning functions
here I divide the data between
train and test subsets and again as in
the previous example I just call
classify on the data without any
trickery without any anything
complicated really happening on the user
side and as you can see I got a 91%
accuracy and you have to keep in mind
that the state-of-the-art accuracy for
this data set is of this order of
magnitude it's not like 99% or something
like that is it reaches about 88% if I'm
not mistaken so this is a pretty good
result
next topic I want to touch touch base on
as the access to pretty tiny neural nets
all of the other presenters have already
shown you the vote from neuron
repository so that is a very good source
of three tiny neural networks we now
have several audio neural networks as
well I will show you an example on how
to recognize key words in a speech
signal so here I am importing the deep
speech to speech recognition model which
is what is in the back end of our speech
recognizer function and as you can see
it does compute a nice result it is not
perfect speech recognized as a better
job because it is able to do some
spelling correction of this result but
what I can do out of this is compute the
probability of each character at any
time so the x-axis is time the y-axis is
which character and then I choose a
collection of transcription candidates
the audio write down perfect timing and
then using a loss layer I can compute
the likelihood of Asics any of these
word at any specific time so this is
what I am doing here and I can plot
these negative these probabilities
serving as a function of time you can
see that perfect has a highest highest
probability at the beginning around 0.5
seconds
sorry perfect is here the blue curve so
at about 1.2 seconds then
has a highest probability at point five
seconds and dog which is not spoken as
you can see its probability is always
several all orders of magnitude less
than the other words this allows me to
post process these curves and figure out
at which times what words are spoken we
have plain audio feature extraction nuts
and this is the same example I've shown
you before just instead of using our
internal automated feature extraction I
explicitly call for this Network and we
do provide the network that is behind
the audio identify function which was
trained by us in-house and you can just
evaluate it as a simple net and it gives
you the probabilities of the audio
classes and again I wanted to show you a
similar example to the classify one I
will do I will attack the same problem
using the audio data file net instead of
the automated automated machine learning
function so I am poor exactly the same
data divided in the same tyrant a sub
sub sub sets and what happens in this
cell is I am per the Volta Moily
identify net molar
and substitute the classification layers
with appropriate classification layers
to classify the data set in this case as
you can see it is just a classifier that
consists in linear layers and
nonlinearities so as it is as simple as
a call to neck trained
and you can see that the end accuracy of
the term this transfer leavening example
is actually pretty significantly higher
than the automated classify example so
the last part I want touch base on is
neural nets from scratch we started
supporting audio in networks with
version 11 3 so the main issue with
audio narrow networks is
[Music]
how to inject an audio object on that it
has a lot of information first it's huge
it has millions of data points secondly
has timing information like the sample
right so how do we inject this
information into a narrow net well that
is what net encode and suffer and for
audio objects we have a lot of different
types of encoders which compute
different features we could just extract
the waveform or we can compute the short
time Fourier transform or the
spectrogram or the mouse back to gum or
the M FCC coefficients and don't worry
about what exactly all deserve
essentially it is a different way of
representing the information in audio
signal possibly by discarding some of
they're less crucial information and the
important part of all this is that these
encoders are extremely efficient either
you have your audio data as all the
objects in in notebook session but you
could also have a huge file collection
on your harddrive for example one
terabyte of all the objects Neph
encoders don't differentiate these two
cases they treat them exactly the same
and the nice thing about it is they are
very efficient
we have huge performance gains with
respect to top-level importing and
feature computation for the net encoders
they are you can compute a variety of
general features and this computation is
extremely efficient and this is your
injection point for neural nets so here
I will show you a quick example about
training a neural net from scratch so
here I am grabbing the spoken digit
commands that set which is essentially
an audio version of am-ness the
collection of audio objects with spoken
digits from 0 to 9 we can define an
audio encoder let me just actually
evaluate the cell sorry I had to disturb
my session and all of these were lost
we can define an audience and a simple
Network and let me just import the
pre-crime Network since I already run
this abomination so you can see the
definition of the encoder is extremely
simple the network is also extremely
simple it's just a chain of the current
layers and then a classification stack
the training call is a very simple as
well and with this minimal amount of
effort we still get hopefully
we still get a high accuracy of 95% on
our test data set on the product page
there is a slightly more advanced
example that trains a sound event
detection not here the definition of the
network is likely more involved but the
end result is that we can figure out
when in time some event happens you can
see in this long audio signal I can
detect when I can hear noises made by a
cat and noise is made by a dot okay so
I'm hoping this was a nice introduction
of the machine learning and neural
network functionality for audio in
version 12 and I'll pass this to the
next presenter which is again at the end
talking about natural language
processing okay so I was saying thank
you thank you Keller and I'm indeed
going to talk about natural numbers
icing and again I'm going to focus on
what's new in the very last version and
if you want to know more about what was
in even point three eleven point two and
so on you can check this product page
which has some examples and kind of a
more detailed lists of what what you
okay so the main new things one you
already had a preview with material
which about transformer architectures
and and pre-trained word embedding in
context which improve many many an epic
test this has been a little bit little
revolution in NLP the last the last this
is this year basically many application
jumped in how we can we can we can do
them thanks to to this these feature
extractors really ok and and these on
our side we worked a lot
function called fix cases and text
content it's actually the same same
function it's just wrapped in different
way and I'm going to talk about that
right now so text case is it's it's a
country we started three years ago but
we need a big update in twelve so so the
idea of Tex Kesey's is to analyze a text
so this is the text from Wikipedia
hopefully it's gonna load it and and
from this page exactly so it's it's a
big string okay from this string we want
to find all over xxx and you can put
pretty much anything as xxx now in the
new version so you can say I'm gonna
find all the persons okay so alright
detecting the entities and it should
return a bunch of strings that
correspond to persons in the text Carl
Perkins Bob Dylan and blah blah blah I
didn't know that Bob Dylan was that
related to champane right okay another
thing so this is just about the syntax
of a function okay I'm gonna talk more
about all the types you can you can
actually ask for so in terms of syntax
you can also say well this result I
don't want them as a string but I'd want
them as interpretation and also I'm
going to set very fine interpretation to
true which mean that if nail cannot have
an interpretation in our famous person
entities then it won't it won't return
them so here we should see only the sort
of notable persons at least the one that
is now a database and stored as recorded
as as entities so you have okay
car-parking Bob Dylan and so on and so
on you can also ask more than one
property so this is a one output instead
of interpretation I'm going to ask ok
interpretation but also one there is no
string and I want the position in the
text
so
you know I mean we're basically doing
the same operation over again and again
could have story but anyway so you go
now Carl Perkins it was actually
mentioned there in the text when Bob
Dylan was mentioned here and here and
here and by the way of course these
entities are useful because then you can
compute things out of them so you can
ask the properties it is classic Wolfram
language things that it kind of
inherited from Wolfram Alpha so you can
ask for example of data birth of obvious
person and you can ask I don't know the
occupation I could you know you grew up
all the occupation and then do a pie
charts to to see typically the
occupation of people that are in
Champaign I mean mentioned in the
Wikipedia page Champaign ok so you can
also ask for more than one type at once
so here we're going to ask for all the
persons and all the countries that are
in this page and
and we're going to ask for all these
properties so now you have an
association as well as as an output
where you are first all the persons and
then all the countries and within this
list they are ordered ordered by
appearance in the in the text and as I
was mentioning we have a new function
called text contents which is a bit like
this one you don't have to specify what
you look for it just gives you a bit
what it wants so in that case it tried
to give you a bit everything it doesn't
give you everything like it's not gonna
say oh this is a verb this is a noun and
things like that like we can say a lot
of things about every word in the
sentences but it's a sort of selection
that you can control as well but anyway
by default for example it will find its
final species the dog is the animal
specie that old dog is the type of food
and position and the probability that
it's actually the correct type and also
a snippet to put in context where it
found so so you can also yes specify the
type that you want or the form that you
want and put many of them but I would
say that this function is more you know
computer to human function let's say you
give you give some text and you have an
idea by just eyeballing data set of
what's in this text and also discovery
function to discover the type that texts
cases can can use but but I think the
most important function is take scales
because you can control every thing that
you want and and this can be well
processed by subsequent by subsequent
programs okay so now I'm going to show a
little bit what you can expect to find
waist exchanges and
there's actually a page text content
types
and you can see here all the type that
you can you can search for which takes
cases I must say that it is experimental
as it's easier
III don't say that we managed to find
all this time very well some of them
might not be great but that that's give
you an idea so you have about 300 types
so you have structural elements power of
speech these all the grammatical stuff
quantities and things like that in on
education elements and then of course
about not all but about like most entity
type in the system like you can find on
the weather station mentioned in the
text so yeah let me show you as examples
so okay let's start with entity so you
can ask for generic entity type so let's
say I take the planet Wikipedia page and
I ask for planets so it should show okay
the Chilean earth earth Mercury when use
actually it's interesting to know it's
Neptunian is actually planet or you know
just I don't know what what is that
anyway there's of course on some always
some definition that are interesting to
think about with these problems alright
so so that's one one any can as many
other entities you can also ask for so
let's remove that for now for specific
planet so I want the planet mass that
you would enter by doing control that's
actually exactly do it you would do
control equal so to enter dance I would
do control equal and then I would type
mass and actually got it right that it
was a planet if it was ambiguous I could
click the alternate interpretation and
say which okay he could also be a
methodological figure or a company and
at least that it's very interesting I'm
going to say company and say and see if
this mass have been found or not and I
don't think any mass company is
mentioned in this thing so there you go
he didn't find any company named mass in
this text okay so let's go back and okay
what I was showing before was this
highlighted snippet so this is just to
show a bit of the context like where was
mass mass found here and so you can
shake that it seems it seems okay okay
and so you have many other entities I
encourage you to try and to tell us if
you think that one is pretty bad like we
have our our test systems that it is
that it's a bit tricky to test this big
function okay another say it's
experimental like we're going to do new
version less active development on these
functions so you can find things like
locations so location is interesting is
any entity that can be pinpoint
somewhere in the world and pinpoint is
bit loose like a country that doesn't
have a specific location but still it
has an approximate like location like
you can define the center of mass or
something like this so a country would
be picked by this location type so it's
going to find all the location and you
can see that here my friends has been
picked up and you have a sort of center
for France and Italy it's been picked up
and Jeremy has been picked up and so on
it is a French region apparently what it
is okay Champaign page
so here I'm going just to show bubble
chart of the location that are in the
page for companion
and here I'm just going to look for city
and country so which are part of which
are part of this location
alright dates that's a useful thing to
search to identify that can be one one
way to give you an idea about about some
text is that what kind of data mentioned
so apparently for some reason I mean I
guess this recent stuff so it makes
sense for some reason there's a cluster
here I don't really know what happened
with champagne at this time but okay
quantities and currency amount another
another type so I'm going to use it on
this text and here I'm going to show
what you can do by having a sort of
custom output so basically all the
possible output of text cases such as
that our string position let me put a
little bigger for you position
probability interpretation you can also
use them as argument of a function and
sometimes it makes your life easier so
here I'm going to find the currency
amounts find that interpretation and
then convert them directly to US dollars
so there you go
okay so you can see this was our
original things like 10 kronor that has
been converted to 1 $1 and and so on
identification element so this one are
usually so here okay
I usually text contents but can be the
same with checks cases any I find the
person the email address IP address
phone number URL the zip code so that's
things you can you search for okay quite
different things in this you can you can
figure out the passage sorry
of texts that speak about a given topic
or that are returned they differ in a
given language for example here I want
all the passage that speak about music
and it grabs I play piano and after oh
actually this is oh wait that was one
sentence that's why I do this this one
still speak about music it speaks about
food as well but I ate carrots hasn't
been picked up by by this and in that
case I input language I input tags that
have several languages and I just want
the one written in French so it should
grab this one and this one if there's no
problem yeah go grab the passages in the
parts that are in French and then we can
also do classic like grammatical
analysis like finding all the verbs
finding all the proper nouns you can ask
further I don't know noun phrases or
verb phrases or things you can ask as
well and to finish I'm going to talk
about the structural elements so again
it's very classic things is just
basically separate things into sentences
so it identify sentences or find all the
words
all the punctuation and and okay this is
just an output form the text text
alignment okay so as you can see it's
quite versatile I call it the Swiss Army
knives natural word processing I believe
that most natural word missing
application are actually this sort of
entity and extended entity recognition
at least most of useful natural
application are this so so I hope it's
going to be used a lot especially with
this new new version and I can tell you
a little bit about what's what's
underneath so for all the you know topic
and language it's basically use built-in
classifiers we have in the language but
otherwise we are now using and it is new
in 12 a big neo network to basically tag
everything so when you rent ecstasies it
tags everything and try to find trying
to kind of classify each words to figure
out to which type they could correspond
to and yeah okay
actually okay maybe I can talk about
that after okay the second thing I
wanted to talk about about transformers
so that will gives you an introduction
already and I want to really stress on
this because it's changing a lot of
things in natural or processing so the
idea of transformer so it's a new
architecture type it's not a recurrent
architecture it's not a convolutional
architecture it's something else that
use self attention and that is
implemented for us by the attention
attention layer okay and that is
explained here in quite over yeah we
should try to have maybe a bit more
concise or whatever it is trated
application explanations but basically
the idea is that contrary to a
convolution where you basically would
process words locally so for example
though with a representation like a
vector cat would have representation
vector and these vectors would be
reprocessed together actually we sat in
that case to compute the next element of
the layer so it's kind of a local
processing and recurrence it's a bit the
same it's you grab the representation of
the and then you grab the representation
of cats and you compute something new
with with these two things and then you
update basically your computation by
adding by reading sat and then by
reading on so the flow information go
this way and the problem with these is
that they have a hard time to quickly
connect regions that are far away so
let's say that for some reason to
understand this sentence it's very
important to pair of the N mat which
actually is not the case in this
sentence but just a better example then
it's going to take a lot of time and
many layers to a finally the information
of and mat to finally meet and if it was
something important to figure out from
the beginning it will be a lost lost
time and in this
result in lost accuracy performance same
for recurrence in this too needs to
communicate with each other you need to
wait quite over here the problem is the
loss of information because you have a
lot of processing happening it is to a
memory of what happened far in the past
and so the attention is a more direct
way in in a way it's it's almost fully
connected except that it's it's if so
sentence is a variable length text by
our lens so we cannot really use a
flicker negative energy but either when
not viable length you could say to sort
of sparse fully connected system and so
this allowed to connect information very
quickly between elements there's two
form there's a self there's a classic
self attention there's one in the causal
attention where the information only
flows from left to right and this is
necessary when you want to create a
language model you cannot create a long
ways model with these sort of
architectures okay so it's very good for
analytic tasks and most likely you will
encounter these transformers by models
that have been trained to create
semantically rich word vectors that use
the context so an example of this one is
birds done by Google and you have it in
the in the neon Network repository and
let's let's show a little bit what's
inside so you have this network that as
a sort of this create the first
embedding for the for the words and then
you have another net chain that you need
to process a meeting we had a bunch of
similarities okay its depth of 12 you
have 12 I don't econet chain let's click
on one I mean structurally I don't eat
all of go the way it sorry friend
and you have so this is okay this one is
an interesting post processing this one
is the most important thing that's an
attention part it's quite a convoluted
it's interesting to analyze and
understand when is and actually the the
interactivity I mean of neon networks in
Mathematica and what language makes it
quite nice to understand what's what is
Network out and so you have these twelve
heads which are attention heads and so
the key thing is attention layer yeah
okay
not going to to go into detail about how
this works let's just apply it to the
cat sat on the mat and the results will
be a vector pretty big for each word
okay so actually at least eyes 1000 so
I'm just going to do a matrix plot of
this of this thing eager so this is just
utilizing so you have eight vectors
because there's eight words I believe
there's actually less than that and
nowhere there's an extra one oh it's
probably doesn't really use word it use
probably to use sub words that's why
anyway and this words it's a semantic
representation but that is in context so
if there was an ambiguity let's say that
cat could mean two different things in
different context if the context enough
then bird should resolve this ambiguity
so there's a lot of understanding about
what the sentence is in this vectors and
that's why it is used as a
pre-processing like in text cases so we
don't use burden text cases because when
we created this network but didn't exist
but we are going to probably we usually
use some with some other things called
elmo's to to pre-process the data and
i've already meaningful vectors before
we start any any training okay so
another one of this model is GPT done by
open a i and you probably heard about it
recently when I did GPT to that is
excellent as a generating text so we
don't have yet GPT to in the repository
it's coming very soon it's coming very
soon so it's probably a matter of weeks
then you can try it yourself but I'm
gonna show you even with GPT what you
can do for language modeling tasks so
here you see it's a parametric net model
so I could say that tasks is just for
exciting features like for Bert but I
could also say oh I want to actually
generate text so long as modeling tasks
and then I can just use GPT and you know
if I say something like the it will tell
me what it thinks should be the next
word so actually it's door here I create
a small function to basically nest over
the generation and just
generating as many words as I want and
so if I generate 30 words starting with
Daenerys Targaryen has three dragons
then it will complete it and only two of
them are new when she passed the first
dragon to sir Barry his sons and
daughter were the first to discover that
Danny and that's that's over and if I do
it again because I'm sampling it should
be a different a different thing so
let's see I'm curious what it does so
anyway we can play with it whispered so
do you said Danny perhaps not numerous
and sorry okay not that very good as the
first one all right so I'm going to stop
here and I hope that you would be able
to use this network to do a lot of nice
NLP applications thank you a TN yeah
thank you so much and thanks to everyone
who stayed online with us we have just
had we were somewhat ambitious we had so
much to talk about with machine learning
and version 12 and we covered a lot
today so good news is we will have a
video link along with notebook downloads
available for everyone that we will send
an email out probably will be next week
Wednesday will shoot for one week from
today well we have all that pulled
together and send you those links by
email but I hope you did enjoy the talks
and learned about some really useful
resources and functionality in the
Wolfram language I want to let you know
that tomorrow at TN has a twitch talk
scheduled at about the same time 1:00
p.m. Eastern it's on our Wolfram Channel
we've put that link in the chat and
Stephen Wolfram I think is even
live-streaming today right now maybe so
if you're interested in checking out
more and interacting with our developers
and what Stephen Wolfram himself you can
you can go to those those twitch talks
we are going to be running them all
throughout the summer on Tuesdays and
Thursdays so we have webinars on
Wednesdays we have twitch talks on
Tuesday Thursday so there's lots of
opportunity
for you to get more information and ask
more questions of both from developers
as you exit today there will be a survey
on your screen very short we appreciate
any feedback you'd like to give us and
look forward to receiving that email
with reminders about future webinars and
a link to the recording we hope to see
you next time thanks everybody I have a
great rest of your day